belle arti ragazzi minuti a questo video
sono fa vj oggi faremo un gioco horror
che ho avuto difficoltà a registrare
quindi ho usato il setup delle ho avuto
problemi a registrare questo progetto
talmente horror che non riesco a
registrarlo quindi ho dovuto usare il
setup delle live infatti c'è la mia
cover per la webcam per questo video è
così perché se non riesco a registrarlo
comunque esiste placement l'ex che
figata sono in macchina che guido io
meno male che non ho fatto porco schifo
non ho sbagliato scappato non volevo
volo guidare io
vabbè nuovo obiettivo trova i ticket
dell'aereo se avete un garage molto
allegro appunto vedo c'è una torcia
molto bene newsflash light o che bella
allegra l'ambientazione sono contento di
questo permesso
ovviamente al mento a c'è un horror dove
c'è la luce base sia lodato gesù ma
veramente sono emozionato non è mai
successo
si accendono le luci in quella macchina
fa veramente vomitare se te lo posso
dire
al continuo da più di mille porte in
faccia ottimo modo per parcheggiare la
bici cos'è casa mia questa io non ho
capito devo trovare i biglietti di un
aereo per quale motivo giardino allegro
fiori allegri ma e mia moglie e al gate
e il lido portare i biglietti ma che ore
sono
siamo un pò tardi permesso a un
deficiente apro la finestra e continua a
sbattere il naso
questa è mia moglie un coltellaccio
fosse utile se vuoi sopravvivere
non che tu voglia una mente lo sta dando
per scontato permesso se nessuno belle
luci che lampeggiano che gioia vivere da
solo mamma mia
cos'è sta roba client for security doors
assicura 05 16 05 16 un numero di
telefono messo 0516 ho tratto del
balsamo dello shampoo professional che a
me servirebbe questo 0516 ricordiamocelo
che il numero del del venditore di
balsami
per me c'è baby un figlio o un cavallo
bellissimo ho un figlio che non c'è però
c'è un figlio quando ciò quando mi fa
veramente una casa brutta se proprio
volete
ok la stanza di maggie porca vacca mi
sembrava avril lavigne all inizio brava
maggie che metti postero horror
bravissima lucian 05 16
mammamia vuota player risolve gli enigmi
così come niente random raga non non
sono non fate domande non sono non so
come ho fatto schifo questo quadro qua
bello bello sono contento che mia moglie
dipinge cose simpatiche poi col
biglietto obiettivo trovai no no no no
perché c'è un quadro brutto se no
sarebbe anche un sì cos'è sta roba qua
c'è una telecamera
beh allegro e non so quale sono stato io
a ucciderla pro sono veramente bello
complimenti e la madonna è la madonna
dimora di satana permesso che succede
che le monache sbatte le porte lì
calmiamoci calmiamoci tutti perchè non
ho non ho la pazienza io di sopravvivere
a certe cose ti ha via via via come si
esce l'asta casali prego di qua è chiuso
con 6 codici c'è una cosa che blocca la
entrata dove sono passato prima sito un
bambino piangere in lontananza sono io a
casa un labirinto questo tornato nel
garage va beh devo fare il giro di nuovo
tutto c'è da andare avanti di qua vabbè
vabbè mi hanno mi hanno murato vivo
non si capisce il motivo capo in
macchina scavo in macchina ciao e stato
bello è stato divertente sono andato via
in macchina cosa che avrei dovuto fare
in tutti gli horror esistenti molto bene
mi sa mi sa che dovevo muovermi ancora
di più a saperlo prima porca vedi che la
maschera e con la liquidi sono stato io
perfetto perfetto è esattamente guardati
proprio le mani mentre guidi prima
regola del dì che ti insegnano quando fa
la patente guardati le mani quando
quindi non guarda la strada non ho fatto
neanche un metro
va bene la torcia c'è quindi bene dove
mi hanno portato suo nome mi ha
trascinato di nuovo dentro
infatti quando siamo dio che apple
proprio ma davanti al quadro poi nè che
dici cos'è acqua e dove c'è stato il
delitto ok sono portato dentro potrei
uscire bambino si è scassato tutto
vabbè andiamo permesso
ma che se c'è il demonio ve lo dovete
dire no vabbè rava che quadri stupisci
sony sta a casa o no no no no no no non
farmi non lascia chiuso stavo scherzando
puoi lasciare che un no no no zio lascia
chiuso norica no lega me ne vado vi
giuro
eh sì prego non c'è nessuno
tu hai visto qualcosa no che strano
pronto vodafone
la nuova offerta quanti gb va bene e
abbiamo capito che vodafone one dei
nostri in questo caso andiamo avanti
peccato perché ci avrei creduto un sacco
ovviamente la porta si è chiusa
ovviamente questa porta non la priva
ormai a look demiroren see the us chi
hai visto ma sono entrato nello specchio
ma serio ma dai che storia adesso quella
porterà a perth aver scritto keep out
tra l'altro bene entriamo allegria leave
the basement aveva ne vado
si vabbè via via veloci chiamata caso
visto la si accende di la doccia nome
dove sono
non vedo lario pedona il nonno morto non
vedevo nulla non c'era la torcia neanche
che sono molto bene perché mi risveglio
provato forse perché almeno portatemi
fuori libia ma basta hachiko quadro è
diverso il quadro è diverso bene sento
gente che ami alita e non ho fatto
ancora nulla si può uscire
no non si può uscire me lo dicevi
tranquillamente cos'è questo pestandolo
seppe rumore quanti tic tac fratello
era comparso qualcosa non so che cosa
molto bene che non l'abbia visto c'è una
polaroid prendi prendi a mi fa vedere
cose che io non vedo come se già ansia
non fosse abbastanza qualcuno che ti
aspetta
c'è una chiazza di sangue gigantesca tra
l'altro qui mica ragazzi mi spunta
qualcuno me ne vado closer ha qui cosa
c'è la chiave qua come eccola è comparsa
dal nulla per freni a venire
apri quota player che suscita fare tutto
subito reagan fenomeno avanti magari non
mi spaccare le bottiglie in corridoio
mentre bossi no vi prego le suore no dai
del suo re nei giochi horror no perché
già ne ho fatti mille di horror cos'è
sta roba qua è diventato un ospedale ad
un certo punto c'è una striscia di
sangue gigantesca beh ottimo che va di
qua al sangue entrato a sinistra bene
buono a sapersi 13 tra l'altro
mickey è successo qualcosa mentre ho
tirato free la polaroid contundente
trova gli altri pezzi rimane che cosa
vedo
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no cara ma quante volte più deboli non
arrampicarti sul divano va beh vedo cose
in questo gioco è un gioco molto
simpatico mi piace
ormai lo so che finisco fa bene mi
stupisco nemmeno più bello però a nel
basement molto meglio di quanto pensassi
find affatto decise nel senso che non ha
proprio deciso domanda lì e solo lì va
bè ragazzi io direi che posso concludere
qua mi sembra da tantissimo tempo non
giocavano rotto così bene mi sembra
molto figo
niente spero che vi sia piaciuto fatemi
sapere se volete il continuo non ho
capito niente però bello wow
per i ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto con
la stessa via che ci sono con te mi
piace anche a me dispiace quindi la
descrizione 106 e noi ci vediamo a un
proseguito beh ragazzi
[Musica]